歡迎收聽股癌，我是謝孟恭，本集節目由善存贊助
你有沒有發現以前每年總是在拼報酬率
現在開始每天要拼自己的精神狀態是否還能撐住一整天
25 歲看 K 線，35 歲看自己的氣色狀態在遞減
這種落差比大盤回檔令人痛心
在股市闖蕩後才發現，每天在市場被教育的同時
我們也默默地被氧化壓力給教育
呼吸、熬夜、壓力等全部都會讓身體氧化，就像是蘋果放在那
沒幹嘛也會變黃變老
多數人想要抗氧化，問題是搞一堆瓶瓶罐罐組合劑太麻煩
那後來就走一個 ETF 流派，善存綜合維他命，直接一顆解決分散風險
我長期喫善存覺得有喫有差
它就是那種已經幫你配好的一籃子
一天一定補充 22 種人體必需營養素，裡面有維生素 C
E、氫、C，這些幫你抗氧化壓力的關鍵營養
等於每天都在幫你打好抗老的基本面
而且它不是亂配，它有 70 年的科學經驗
還分男女不同年齡設計的專業配方
想要在喫的男性善存，就有增量的 B1、B12 和鋅，讓活力充沛思緒清晰
工作家庭都有超強的續航力
買給老婆的女性善存，有增量的 C 鈣鎂，給女性好氣色
好代謝、好狀態由內而外散發出來
簡單講就是善存不會叫退休族跟上班族都搞同一套配置
如果說是每天盯盤加上班的上班族就靠成人善存
如果想要照顧好爸媽就靠銀寶善存
讓長輩維持熟悉又安心的身體狀態
持續精彩過每一天
其實這跟投資有點像，不一定每天漲停板單不能夠持續的在賠
一天一顆善存就是有個專業團隊在幫你投資健康的狀態
投資你會做的資產配置身體也要
那這是我真實推薦可以長期持有的最佳選擇
就靠善存把一家的健康基本面顧好，氣色活力都在線
那有需要的朋友可以在資訊欄這邊找到更多的說明與連結
真的蠻多東西是要等到你懂得換位思考
或甚至是不懂得換位思考
最慢最慢就是等到你被強迫換位置之後，換腦袋之後
你就會開始去理解一些東西跟自己想像的可能不太一樣
像我小時候聽到自己的朋友可以去上什麼夏令營的
我都覺得蠻羨慕的啊，太爽了吧
竟然夏天他爸媽可以送他去哪裡上課
去哪裡玩
上課不是那種傳統的上課，不然誰會羨慕，就是你去那個地方
一般來講就是去玩，去打漆彈，去做什麼奇怪的事情
不然有些人甚至是可以去到海外，會覺得說，哇
他們的家長真的是超級寵他們
對他太好了，就是你的思考是以這個同學作為本位
會覺得他好像這樣子過了一個非常美好的夏天
那等到自己當老爸之後呢
特別是經歷了前面的幾個夏天
一開始你會很有新鮮感啦
因為就是一個新生命的誕生嘛
陪他玩或什麼的，但最後面還是會慢慢理解一件事情
就好像是不管你多熱戀的情侶
最後就會發現說你每天待在一起
老實講是沒有辦法的，還是要有一點那種小別勝新歡的成分
如果說你們每天可能只需要相處三到四個小時
其實我覺得那個相處的品質會比你相處一整天來得好
那所以一開始當然會想要用盡全力去陪孩子，只是到後來就發現
可能是第一體力不支，第二可能是就跟任何人一樣
你每天跟他在一起，你總是會有一點厭煩
所有的小缺點就會被放大
所以就盡量去抓出一點距離
這時候夏令營的產生，就對我們來講是一個老天給的恩惠
把小朋友送出去
整個夏天我就只需要擔心一半，因為一半是夏令營
另外一半還是可以出去玩
相較之下，你的煩躁感就會降低非常多
孩子可能也蠻高興的，他可以到一個地方去跟其他同學玩之類的
就是一個雙贏的策略
所以如果預算夠的話，基本上夏令營一定都會把他抱好抱滿
可是因為到夏令營還有一小段時間
所以我們家就先全部帶出來
先做一下國旅，八月之後可能才會出國去旅行
「今天就來到凱渡飯店，我覺得蠻屌在宜蘭這邊
其實我們以前宜蘭的度假都蠻喜歡去那個礁溪老爺啦。」去年的這個時間
我也是在教習老爺，那時候就是我入坑尼姬的時候
印象非常深刻，那時候為了抽那個水桃樂司
可能花了大概五六萬臺幣吧
我就上頭了，然後就想要把它全部抽爆，抽到 MAX
那也因為有這個事件作為載體啦
所以就比較記得說，原來去年的這個時間
我就記得我那時候是躺在老爺裡面在那邊抽卡
別人在那邊玩，我在那邊抽卡
今年本來也是想要再去老鹽
因為去習慣的地方就會一直想要去，跟一開始不太一樣
一開始去旅行的時候會想要去新地方
後來我都一直只想去熟悉的地方
只是因為他被訂滿了
我就想到說
我有蠻多朋友在推薦說有一個在海邊的飯店叫凱渡
可以去看一下
可是不知道為什麼他的評價看起來好像沒有很高
就八點多分，八點多分直覺就覺得說應該是會哪裡有雷之類的
但反正就是帶孩子去玩嘛
後來你帶孩子玩的地方就不會太在意了
你的想法就是反正孩子只要玩得開心就好
所以像那時候我們也去一個在桃園的南方莊園
那個我就是會覺得說，如果你叫我來，我就不會來第二次
可是因為孩子在那邊游泳 BBQ 玩得很高興，所以就為了他就還是會再去
那一樣的道理，就是我們現在其實有蠻多的思考
就是為了孩子去做這個核心的規劃
所以看到這個凱渡的飯店
他在海邊有蠻多有的沒有的東西
他有一些什麼海水游泳池，想說就來吧
就令我超意外，其實我蠻喜歡這個地方
他晚上的 Buffet 也是蠻好喫的，小朋友喫得超開心
他有一個 Kids Club,Kids Club 裡面有一些是換代幣的電玩
有一些是可以用租借的，像他就搞了一個類似那種木頭車車
然後你就可以跟你孩子拖鞋子上去坐在車車裡面打 Switch
在家裡打 Switch 好玩非常多，所以我們就在那邊玩了兩款遊戲
還有一些球類的東西可以去做租借
所以我就感覺我的孩子玩到瘋掉了
在泳池或是在 Kids Club 都很高興
然後就覺得說以後應該會再多帶他來
然後在這邊遇到了蠻多的地方的尼爾蘭陣線，大家都稍微的打個招呼
就知道說每個人都是 You feel me,I feel you，我們都是陪小孩來這裡
意外的這個地方其實蠻讚的
有一個地方爸爸就跟我講說他們已經來好幾次了
他以前也是去老爺，我說我這次也是沒有訂到老爺才跑來這裡
好像是一個備選的東西，可是來了之後有點那種上頭了
迷上了，就覺得以後可以再多來幾次
因為孩子真的玩得非常的開心
所以我覺得地方爸媽如果你們不知道要幹嘛的話
後面可以看一下這家飯店
特別是以孩子作為核心， 我覺得他們會蠻高興的
那家長方面呢， 反正就是窗， OK, 人氣， 會涼
再來就是說泡澡的地方，有，那晚上有 Buffet 可以喫，那我還額外再訂了一個
他有跟江振誠有合作一個，那也不知道是什麼東西
反正我就請 A 君幫我處理什麼 Fine dining 我說有沒有包廂
又有包廂，低銷三萬，算起來也還好
因為可能全家加起來就七八個人
一個人三千塊，就快低銷啦
你這隨便點個九就低銷了
你看又有包廂，可以在裡面，不知道，就是一家人在那邊
感覺是蠻快樂的事情，所以我覺得這個地方真的是挺好的
然後再來也有看到他的目錄上面有寫說什麼可以坐船出去啊
什麼有的沒有
就覺得說這個地方應該是以後可以常常來
那宜蘭真的是一個就非常喜歡的地方
最近一個好朋友也在宜蘭買了房子
他本來問
我說要不要來宜蘭搞一下
我不是想潑他冷水
因為他們正在備孕中，我就跟他講說，幹，我跟你講
後來你要帶孩子出去，像我們這次帶兩個出來
大的已經是算可以自理了
沒什麼事情，可是光是小的
那個行李箱就可能要拉兩個以上
因為有一些他要用的用品
或是一些什麼消毒的東西
飯店不一定有，或是說他有
可是他不一定是你要的一個規格
所以跟你講，帶小孩出去超麻煩
特別是那種兩三歲以下的
超級辛苦，你現在買一個在宜蘭，然後你想像中是說
呃，我週末帶他來玩，很開心，但實際上的狀況就是
你們可能累個半死啊，那可能平常又有人要來你家看小孩或什麼的
你週末就只想好好休息，因為你已經在那邊買了房子
你就不得不去嘛，那你要拉大包小包的東西過去之外呢
到那邊就是怎麼講，可能也沒有像在家裡這麼方便嘛
因為要有這嬰幼兒的東西其實滿多時候是很麻煩的
那再來就是他長大一點會發生這種事情，像我兒子現在四五歲
他就有他媽吉啊，他有幾個是那種好媽吉，好媽吉在哪他就想在哪
這還只是四五歲而已喔，你想像他媽的小學或是國中
那假日可能他就想跟他好媽吉可能去旁邊哪裡打個電動或什麼的
你叫他要跟你去宜蘭或什麼的，他一定不想跟你去啦
所以我那時候就一直怎麼講，因為我知道他已經買了
我也不想潑他冷水，可是我就是偷偷跟他講說，媽的
等到你有小孩之後，你想法可能不太一樣，但沒關係啊
反正買了就買了嘛，十歲以後他們可能還是會想要來跟你烤肉之類的
可是就這個中間會比較辛苦一點，所以我就覺得說像這種
你看我們就是另一包東西，雖然也不是一包，他媽的
蠻多包，然後就可以來這邊就到處找一些飯店去住一下
其實算起來也是非常划算的啦
而且你不用對這個地方有 commitment
你不用說什麼買了房子你要照顧他，或什麼有的沒有的
這是一個挺好的選擇啦
那希望大家在接下來的暑假都可以過得開心健康
跟孩子可以一起寫下非常美好的回憶啦
雖然剛剛前面感覺是有一點那種小抱怨
在想說跟孩子整天在一起很累
但仔細想想，你看喔，你跟一個小嬰兒，你們只有兩個夏天
因為兩歲以後他就可能就不是小嬰兒，他就是變成是 baby 了
那接著跟 baby 可能有三個夏天，就是他會極度仰賴你
那等到他可能五六歲之後呢
他已經開始有自己的朋友
他有自己的想法，所以他就是一個小孩
那小孩的夏天可能不知道也就是五六個
然後接著可能就一切都進入一個終點，他們會有自己的生活
那最終呢你就是隻有你跟你的老伴，所以呢，嗯
雖然有時候會覺得可能陪小孩還蠻累的
因為同時主持人- 我覺得很有趣的一點是，當然可能很像在講幹話
因為我們有孩子的時候，一般來講都是在青壯年嘛
臺灣比較例外啦，那臺灣或是說像我太太西班牙那邊
其實蠻多人是很晚生啦，三四十歲才生，年輕的時候都不想要嘛
或是說壓力太大什麼的，然後等到老了就突然間想要去
趕快上末班車，當然風險也會放大
如果你是走比較常規的生育時間
其實剛好是你的事業起飛
你最多工作、你最累的時候
我們家是還好，只有我自己在工作，太太可以花比較多時間陪孩子
我自己有時候也覺得蠻不好意思的
因為我也想花時間陪孩子啊
但就很累啊，就真的超累的啊
像這個禮拜又是那種戰鬥禮拜嘛
像我們昨天在喫那個 Buffet 的時候
我們是兩桌啦，A 君跟他的女朋友有來
再來就是我岳母跟我太太或什麼的
我也不知道為什麼，就理論上我應該要坐在我們自己孩子的這一桌
要陪他們嘛，要什麼的，可是我就是先去拿個東西
我就先坐在隔壁桌的最角落，我就先開始他媽的狂喫
我就覺得我超餓，我已經一整天超累
然後又要開車來宜蘭或什麼
我先把自己餵飽之後，然後喝個烏龍茶，冷靜一下
OK，然後就換我去餵孩子，那也非常感謝就是家人可以這樣互相扶持啊
有些人可能是主外，有些人主內
然後可以把這件事情做好
但就家長們真的是不容易啊
那可以找到一些現在在外面其實對孩子友善的地方也越來越少
我覺得很合理，因為在這個世界上願意去生小孩的人是越來越少了
所以當然大家就會去玩出一些新把戲
就像是如果今天生孩子的是絕大多數的話
或者說生育率是稍微正常一點
像那時候自己去美國會體驗就覺得
哇，大家都會覺得說你的孩子好像是很重要的東西
那個態度會差非常多，可是在臺灣我們就會擔心說孩子會不會不小心吵到別人
會不會影響到別人
可以找到這種親子飯店，每個人都有帶孩子
每個人都是捏住自己的軟帶
每個人都是一樣砍的，就會覺得在這個地方是非常的放鬆
有這樣的地方可以稍微喘口氣，我也覺得是挺好的
整體來講，它是一個……蠻有趣的體驗
你在每天可能睡前你回頭想
你覺得自己非常的幸福，可是在當下你覺得說他媽的也太累
所以有一句話我還是覺得非常的到位
就是關於生育孩子這件事情
一天太長一年太短，大概差不多就是這樣的一個感受
那就希望大家在暑假快樂，以上
那接下來我們就來進入上個話題
那在上個禮拜三的時候有跟大家分享一下
我覺得現在盤面的狀態是
如果你想要去追一些強勢股的話
你就會被修理，然後在昨天跟前天
專門在做這種強勢或是漲停策略的人
都有提到這件事情，就說真的是一直被幹
可是我自己覺得在禮拜四禮拜五的時候， 開始有一些東西變得不太一樣
有一些那種所做的東西，我感覺說就整個氣勢是不太一樣
不太像前面就是可能蠻多人在做進攻的時候
就同時會有很多人跑出來
但我覺得也合理啦， 因為前面剛經歷過一個小型的修正嘛
所以當重新拉起來的時候
可能就有蠻多終於可以解套的傢伙就會想把東西都賣掉
所以很多時候我都會想去問這些人
我都希望可以去開一個端到端的加密連線
跟這些人的腦袋去做連結說，你會不會做股票，你在幹嘛
人家在幫你拉
人家拿錢在那邊砸， 你在那邊拼命賣， 你是他媽的猴子是不是
就你知道他是猴子，因為你知道這些人他們最後面都會後悔
他們就等到下個高的時候再跑回來追
但就真的蠻多人都在搞這樣子的操作，反正就是亂追啦
然後接著解套就拼命賣，真的很多散戶都是在這樣子搞
那但是呢，有時候當這些人他們眾志成城，他們一堆人聚在一起
或者說盤面真的前面有去做出一些比較不好看的心態的時候呢
你就會注意到，就到一些特定的地方，他的賣壓真的是非常大
所以你本來想要進去做一個強勢股， 你可能被打到， 你自己也變賣壓
因為你被打到之後， 你想說大家都不要玩了， 沒關係， 就一起來丟
那所以就變成他會稍微的震盪一點，但這種震盪的時間點呢
一般稍微的在持續一陣子之後
那當盤面開始持續的去攻出新高的話呢
我覺得就是大家的資金就會再次的凝聚起來
那到時候強勢族羣呢就會非常容易的去做識別
那在禮拜三跟大家分享的時候是有注意到
因為被動元件是第一波在這個修正之後立刻轉強的東西
那隨後呢功率元件也是，所以其實就還是在被動跟功率這邊
我覺得是非常好識別，就是市場的資金是押注在這些地方
那他們是率先的轉強，那轉強之後，你就會看到一堆人
他可能看到他的強要跳上來嘛，你跳上來你就被修理
就像我可能禮拜三跟大家講的，你跳上來，你去追那場田
你就被修理
好，但這個修理呢，可能就是稍微的持續一陣子，因為有些人要下車
因為有些人他本來前面被套到，他也是亂追的
那然後這個籌碼稍微的洗乾淨之後呢
我覺得啦，就是如果在下一波再持續拉上去的
他應該就會回到正常的盤面
也就是那些強勢的東西就有機會會那展現出一些比較厲害的延續性
所以大概是這樣子去做觀察
我覺得看起來是蠻有可能要準備要射出去
那只是當然我們一般都會等到確實就有看到
就是你真的走出去，那當然最明顯就是大盤直接有一個新高
那就不用講了，那就代表說修正就結束了
在這樣的狀況之下，就會持續地把資金給推進去，所以目前的規劃是這樣
在過去的一個禮拜，雖然是有蠻多新的事件的產生
但還是主要圍繞在那幾個元件
我們上集有跟大家聊到說，有一些 lead time 增加
然後有一些大家在接下來會開始看到漲價性發出的情形
當然還是要強調一下，這個漲價性發出是在講產業面的部分
那股價面其實很多都噴出了
所以不代表它發漲價性它就要繼續噴出
你懂我意思嗎
因為它前面已經噴很多，很多都噴兩三倍以上了
那不確定，但是我們因為產業面的東西還是要持續跟大家 cover
所以就是提到說你會開始在七月看到密集的漲價性的產生
那最近在一些 ODM 跟 EMS 的朋友也提到說他們開始買不到一些功率元件
像是 MOSFET，在一些應用上面，甚至已經出現斷貨的情形
是買不到
所以這個算是房間裡的大象吧
因為在過去的幾個月，我自己也都是在盯被動元件為主嘛
然後是直到被動元件開始出現一些震盪之後
我才開始去撈市場其他題材
才發現說，哇靠，既然房間裡面有一隻大象，這些功率的零組件呢
其實他們也開始出現 lead time，然後甚至是漲價的情形
而且是完全是不輸被動元件的
那在這個禮拜我覺得開始進入到一點那種白熱化的情形
因為真的開始已經有一些人是表示說買不到這個料件
那甚至有一些業界的朋友就想說
欸這些東西買不到料的話要買哪一檔
大家都開始去做這個研究
那我覺得這時候在產業的朋友他們就有一些優勢
因為他們就知道說是哪幾家公司他有缺料嘛
那如果你不是產業的朋友的話呢
那可能就會要花比較長的一段時間才會明白到底發生什麼事情
甚至等到一些漲價性開始對外連發的時候才會注意到
因為我們這個節目會持續跟大家 cover 目前在產業上的一些情形
所以就是有注意到說功率元件真的開始有變化
出大事的情形，他們可能也會在後面出現不亞於被動元件的一些情形
只是當然我們不知道說在股價表現上是不是也會非常的恐怖
因為被動元件是漲數倍，然後這些東西都漲數倍
那功率的話我們不太確定
可是目前純用產業的角度來看的話
這個缺貨狀況也是蠻嚴重的
所以就會回歸到我們
可能在好幾集前
就有跟大家聊到說這些功率元件的
他們的構造是這樣子，絕大多數其實都是以 IDM 的一個狀態
他們是一條龍全包，從設計到製造、後端的封裝、測試到出貨
可能在接下來缺貨的情形之中
他們會是屬於比較有優勢的
自己是有辦法去掌握產能的
當然，有些他雖然自己是沒有產能
在臺灣的一些公立元件廠他是 fabulous 的一個情景
這也不代表說他不行，因為他只要有辦法去 secure 到他的產能
不管是透過母公司，然後再來可能是透過集團的一些資源
所以這時候你去掌握集團就很重要
就是你要知道在同個集團之下
你可以去看一下他大股東是誰
他們可能是有辦法去 share 一些資源的
他在後段的封裝是有辦法有人幫他做
或者說他們可能在過去的數年有去找一些不管是海內外的晶圓廠
我去簽約，我去確保說他可以拿到他要的產能的話
那這些其實也都沒有什麼太大的問題，就他們都可以是受惠的
但如果說你今天手上是沒有產能的話，就會比較尷尬一點
但這個也很難講，像那時候在記憶體的一個分析上面
我自己也是抱持這樣子一個想法，那只是沒有想到說
你看到一些模組廠，他們真的是賺到爛掉，為什麼
他雖然自己是沒有產能嘛，理論上就把庫存賣光，就差不多就沒了嘛
可是呢，他們也夠敢賭，就是他們去賭說這次跟以前可能是不太一樣
他是一個比較大的 cycle
那所以即便那時候已經開始出現一些漲價，他一樣是抱著重金
那甚至去跟股東募資，都是要去搶這些料
那後面如果被他賭對，就真的有繼續漲價的話
他們可能還是會賺贏那些廠商喔
我覺得產業的東西有時候很難講，原因在此
事在人為，還是要看大家怎麼樣去搞
理論上，你有辦法去掌握產能的，你是贏家
但是有些可能夠大膽的，又給他賭對的話，他可能也可以賺到蠻多錢
那除了在公立員間這邊，我們有注意到說，嗯
真的是有蠻多顆料開始出事情
從其實大概快一個月前跟大家分享到現在，它是持續的在惡化之中
那同時呢，我們有再發現一些不一樣的東西
其實我是先在整個臺股的族羣沒有注意到說
欸，封測特別的強勢，那當然封測它其實是蠻廣的一個故事啊
比較老的，像日月光或是說靜眼店，大家都熟悉有 KYEC
那他本身幫 NVIDIA 做的，所以他其實已經算是那種 Household name
就是大家都知道的
那在過去一陣子我們就有注意到說
其實整體的族羣是長得還蠻好看的
那也有聽說在一些 IC Design House
那當然這可能就不方便去點名是哪幾家公司
但是在業界的朋友應該是新有 77N 啦
因為在封裝這邊是被漲很多
那就我理解呢，其實在肺炎期間當時被漲的一個價額大概是落在 10 到 20% 之間
但這波呢，我們是開始有去瞭解到一些 Design House
他被他後段的封裝廠去報
他下一個 Q 報價的時候，他是直接漲了可能 30% 甚至高了我聽到 40-50%
就不知道到底發生什麼事情
所以我個人認為說這也是一種排擠效應的呈現
因為 AI 的需求過於的強大，那這些封裝廠呢
他們其實現在可以去挑客人
所以他就會告訴你說多少錢我纔要做
如果你沒有辦法給我這個錢的話
那我不做，因為反正我後面還有很多的選項
我們也注意到說在一些公立的封裝廠有類似的情形正在準備發生中
就是說封裝可能是後面市場有機會會想要去關注的一個題材跟故事
它過去其實它一直都不是一個很香的故事，可是自從 AI 的誕生之後
那我覺得封裝廠它有點像是說那種轉型變身的啦
那因為剛剛前面有提到說掌握產能的為王嘛
那 IDM 的話他們自己就有這些廠方
那當然也是有可能他們自己的廠方也不夠，也要去外面去找外包的
那其他的話呢可能都會需要去找到這些外援
所以包含說像以前大家都非常熟悉的
你在 AI 要獲得勝利的話呢
不只是你的產品要做得好
重點是你要做得出來，所以大家都要去巴結臺積電嘛
那一樣的道理
你就可以把它套用在這一系列
可能是比較偏向成熟製程的晶圓製造廠
不管是什麼六寸或是八寸的
或者說他們的後段的一些封裝測試廠
那他們的一個敘事邏輯呢
其實會跟 TSM 或是說 TSM 後面的不管是 Encore 或是略廣那樣的故事是類似的
只要可能是套用在不同的產品線
可能是在一些比較偏向成熟製程的東西
或甚至是功率元件，一些導線架相關的內容
這個在後面都有機會被看到
那所以目前初步看是市場的故事
還是圍繞在這幾個關鍵的零組件
以前大家都把它認為是比較小的料件
你說雖然這個功率元件
它是主動型料件感覺又稍微的聰明一點點
可是就大家也是把它視為是便宜的小料嘛
那被動元件更不要講了
就它甚至是趁機論量在賣的那這個 AI 的下一個運行有點像
那時候從一開始是專注在那些毛利極高的 design house
然後到晶圓製造公司
其實他們現在毛利率也都拉到很高
然後現在都跑到一些這些感覺是比較枝微末節的小料件
那他們也有機會在後面，基本上像被動元件是已經確定了啦
那功率元件的話可能就是醞釀正準備發生中
我覺得他們的毛利都可能會拉到一個蠻高的數字
所以反映的就是這些科技巨頭真的很有錢
你看把大家的毛利全部都拉起來
因為大家都是要在短時間內去完成這些搶貨嘛
所以就是去對產業造成一些蠻大的改變
所以除了就是前面聊到的像是被動元件或是供應元件
然後到現在的封裝端呢，我覺得都有機會會是下一棒
就是會有機會會帶著這個市場向前衝
那只是因為我們目前還沒有辦法很明確的確定
因為才剛經歷完修正，那接下來就是看誰轉強
基本上轉強的東西帶頭跟著大盤一起新高的就死了
就可以確定他就死了，那個我猜有機會在下禮拜或下禮拜就會去見分曉
到時候我自己也是非常期待
但總之我也去完成了相對應的一個佈局
那在這個禮拜有一個蠻大的新聞
就是說 Meta 要去投入 Neocloud 的一個建制
就是他想要去把一些冗餘的算力拿出來出給大家
那這個在市場上立刻就掀起了蠻多討論
那絕大多數的評論都是認為說這個就代表說 meta 不要玩的
所以你去看一些那種 X 的，他們把它稱為什麼大 V
就是整天去發表意見的一些
其他都喜歡放那種動漫的頭像
蠻多的意見都在講說這個是 meta 不玩的
那我們這邊講一下我們自己的看法
因為我們還是除了自己有一些思考能力之外的
然後再來就是我們在產業的一些朋友，就我們的理解
當然這可能是我們這一端的一些想法，那後面也都可能會改變
就我們當下所可以拿到的資訊去做一個判斷，Meta 他是打算要 Double Down
什麼意思
就是他是想要去靠這個東西賺錢
他不是說， 喔， 完了， 我的 AI 算力不知道怎麼用， 拿出來租人家好了
他不是這樣，他是打算要去投資，然後再去搞更多的算力
然後把那些可能比較 Legacy 的像是 Hopper 系列
這些東西可能在新一代的 AI 訓練上面發力的程度沒有這麼大
我就拿出去租給別人
所以他其實是想要去做更多建置的
那當然這個後面可以再觀察各個企業的動向
再去做一個驗證
就我們目前所瞭解到的，包含像是一些顏調的單位
我有去看了一下大家所提到的一些資料
提到說其實在 meta 內部他們是
本來已經出現一些分歧的狀態，就是有人想要衝
可是 CFO 想要去踩煞車，希望說大家不要這麼衝
但因為現在找到一些解方了嘛
就是說我們可以盡量的衝
因為我們沒有用到的東西我們可以拿出去租別人
那就導致說現在公司變成只有共識，那我們確實就可以衝
因為我們可能沒有用到的東西，或者還沒有用到的東西
它不會形成一個浪費，它是有辦法可以去外租給別人去賺錢的
所以理論上這個事情應該是要把它解釋為他們要繼續衝
我覺得目前看會是這樣子
那當然是要等後續的一些事情去做驗證
只是稍微講一下自己的看法
因為市場上我看絕大多數的看法是在講說這代表說 Meta 他要退出 AI 競賽
我不覺得這是他要退出 AI 競賽
他只是想要去做 NeoCloud 的一個 business
外加自己對祖克柏的一個認識，雖然他不是我媽姊
我也不認識他，我只是有用他產品的一個消費者
我們從以前看祖克柏，他是一個非常厲害的，怎麼講
你可以講說是，講抄襲不好聽
就是說在商業上本來就是大家會互相模仿
去效仿一些成功的商業模式
所以包含說像把 Instagram 收下來
然後去模仿 Reels，然後在元宇宙看到別人在那種拿自己用得更大力
推得超猛的，雖然後面感覺有點烙賽
但我們知道說祖克柏就是他絕不缺席
然後在 AI 時代也是看到這些巨頭在衝
臉書身為一個他沒有辦法去把算力對外賣的一個公司
因為你知道這些巨頭其實他們可以衝嘛
因為就算他的東西用不完
他都可以做成是 Cloud 然後去出租給別人嘛，那可是呢
Meta 的東西是自用的，可是他照樣跟大家衝
那他是一個很猛的公司啊
就是他只要找到各種風口浪尖的東西
有這種機會他都會去衝刺的人
所以呢，呃，祖克柏我是相信說他去做的每個東西
他當下都會抓到那個趨勢，當然我們事後回頭看看
發現說蠻多都是爛鬼，蠻多都可能會失敗，但是我不會想去算這個
就類似說 Google 也去做了蠻多的爛尾投資，最後面發現是沒有辦法
可是我認為身為這些巨頭
或者說掌握大量現金流的公司
他們本來就應該要這樣子做
因為他們其實不怕花錯錢
只怕沒有花到錢沒有跟到
花錯錢對他來講是小事情
很多的訪問，關於這些巨頭，老闆或董事長他們
其實都有去講過類似的東西
所以在我的角度會認為說，他要去做 Neo Cloud 的話
其實需要害怕的是這些 Neo Cloud
而不是說大家會擔心 AI 建制是不是要停，不是
是他要來跟這些 Neo Cloud 來搶生意
而且他的做法都是那種超級癡漢，黏在後面
然後他會投入很多的錢， 可能會真的去掃掉一些玩家
所以他的加入是對這些人， 我覺得算是一個比較不好的消息啊
但病還很大啦，就是我們總是要往好處想的是
總不可能多一個 Neo Cloud 的 player
然後就導致 AI 的供需就平衡了吧
那代表 AI 的供需其實也沒有像大家想像的這麼的緊俏， 對吧
所以短期上應該會是一個消息上的一個衝擊啊
可是長期上我覺得，這個對於建制的故事來說並沒有造成太大的改變
甚至是某個程度上它有機會是它準備要換檔再加速
然後去做更多的投資，因為它知道今天一些冗餘的東西或是一些 Legacy 的產品
它是有辦法找到一個出海口
因為它本來是沒有辦法的
他本來東西都是純自用，所以我認為他又一次的
因為他都是模仿或是去效仿別人
他一定是看到伊朗的不管是 SpaceX 或是 X 下面的 Colossus
因為他拿去租，然後結果發現說他竟然一年就可以回本
他一定是發現說靠北，原來錢可以這樣子賺
因為本來伊朗的東西他也是打算自己要拿去建置
所以我們知道 XAI 現在有點卡關的情形產生
Meta 我們不確定是不是卡關，雖然看起來像，但先不管他到底是卡關與否
他一定就是看到了 SpaceX 或是 X 的這個 classes，原來可以這樣子賺錢
媽的，我也要賺
因為這跟他過去的行為模式是一樣的
就是他發現哪邊可能有東西
然後這個池漢就會衝進去，然後在那邊鑽
所以就有機會會有蠻好搞頭的啦
那我有把相關的一些想法丟到臉書上面
那我看到下面有一個聽眾的留言就還蠻有趣的
他就說反正 meta 的東西呢，你知道他就算最後面找不到客人
他也有詐騙集團可以跟他組
這個聽起來像是一個幹話，可是我不知道，越來越覺得有可能
因為 Meta 的那些詐騙，像最近大家知道在臉書上面那個三寶吧
有一個三寶吧整天在那邊洗，那個就是詐騙
竟然這麼簡單的一個東西
它可以用一些 Keyword，我很難想像這對他來講是一個技術挑戰
我只能夠認為說這就像是我們當時的判斷
其實 Meta 是有意的去放行一些東西讓他這樣去做
或者說他有意的不要去做太密集的趕盡殺絕
因為他的金屬很大一部分就是這些詐騙
所以不曉得，搞不好後來，反正有人跟他租就好啦
你只要不要太明擺著是用到犯罪集團角度來租
你去報一個主持人- 某家公司，你換個皮，弄個防火牆
你來跟我租算力，我就租你啊，我就租你啊
搞不好他可以找到更屌的生意
就是這些灰色經濟的東西，不然我很難去想像
我也不想去感覺像是抹黑 meta
可是你知道那個詐騙的東西，他們會說他們有在抓
他們真的有在抓，我真的有看到
你知道那個三寶壩他洗了這麼久耶
你把三寶壩封掉有很難嗎
就是我不曉得，甚至我們自己在後臺下一些關鍵字有時候他也不會生效
所以我就感覺說，嗯，對啦，反正祖克柏他有很多的出海口啦
他先去抄 Colossus，然後他跟的時間點又夠快
所以他的算力應該是有辦法都可以賣掉
然後再來就是，如果後面他真的要跟別人競爭的話
他又有一些額外的管道可以去賣一些這個灰色產業的東西
他說不定可以做得比那些 Neocloud 都來得更好
這是自己的一個小小的觀察
第一位，高雄許光漢他爸
孟恭親家公你好，小兒三歲人稱高雄許光漢
每次被人說小孩像爸爸都比直接稱讚我還讓人輕飄飄
尤其是這些話從妹子的口中說出
能夠掰彎小兒的也只有諾亞安哥了
希望親家公可以繼續努力增加我們結為親家的機率
祝福孟恭一家快樂平安早日與我們團聚
「祝各位兄弟育兒快樂！」下面一位 Lucky77:「嗨孟恭，很高興被你唸到留言
聽了很久您的 podcast，很喜歡您的嗓音分享的日常跟對事情的看法
你的想法讓我很認同，我的男友也變成了做尿派
最近發生了人生轉折，經歷了一場生死關頭，很幸運挺過來了
我在加護病房醒來沒有多久
護理人員問我有沒有想聽什麼廣播
我就請他幫我播股癌，只因為當時很痛不舒服的時候
聽著你的聲音就能夠睡著
這算讚美嗎
那我很謝謝我的爸爸媽媽妹妹以及我的男友
在我最困難的時候
都在身邊不離不棄的照顧我
謝謝你們沒有放棄我才能熬過難關
最後可以請你用肌肉猛男的聲音跟我男友說
7 月 7 號生日快樂愛你喔
謝謝孟恭，願你們全家平安健康快樂幸福
我們先恭喜 Lucky 77 順利出院，也非常恭喜有這麼好的一家人可以持續陪伴著你
我是不知道啦，如果說今天是剛康復，就是要聽股癌的話
如果今天我是護理師的話，我就會想說，媽的，這個傢伙應該是套很多
現在應該很緊張
醒來第一件事情，先關心股票的狀況是怎麼樣，先看外面的市場是怎麼樣
當然非常榮幸，非常榮幸在你面臨這種生死交關的一個時刻
今天很多時候我聽到這種東西都覺得蠻奇怪的
就像是有些人跟我講說，他們的家人可能在最後一刻的時候要聽 Gooaye
我想說，不知道，就蠻奇怪的啦
但說不定我們之後在天上也可以辦一個天中見面會
數年之後
Judy KK，孟恭大大您好，男友一直都是您的忠實粉絲
之前甚至會特地跑到林口三井想說可不可以遇到您
那男友平常也熱衷於跟我分享您說過的題材跟各種事情
託您的福，今年上半年我跟男友的績效都表現得很好
真的很感謝一路上有您的陪伴
那最後希望您能夠祝查理 7 月 5 號生日快樂，每天開心
身體健康，績效大爆射，也祝福您全家健康平安，每天喜樂
祝你們兩個快樂
下面五位
孟恭老聽眾，最近轉職綠色公股銀行，因為有信貸
主管認為我都在炒股票，甚至擔心我賠錢會偷客戶的錢
因此錯失離專的機會，臨時換成一位沒有意願的上位
我今年的臺股淨值從最低 12 萬做到前天最高 360 萬
是不是可以考慮離職專職投資
還是以機會成本來看，建議淨值達到多少
括號封控回檔時要跑得掉再離開
畢竟上班的時間很難看盤
那最後祝老公 Lisa，諾亞，安哥，Choco，身體健康，闔家平安
360 萬可不可以就很認真出來搞股票
以我自己的經驗是絕對是可以啊。300 多萬， 假設你今天是沒有家勒， 沒有孩子
短期內沒有結婚，沒有要經營家庭
家裡沒有要跟你要什麼生活費
甚至更早就有機會就可以了
只是當然我們不會想去鼓勵大家做這樣的事情
只是必須得很客觀跟大家講說
蠻多跑去交易室的人或是像我們這種在家自己搞的
都是在甚至更小的時候就有辦法自己出來，當然自己出來
某個程度上都是有一點賭的成分
時不時也會聽到有些人要回去上班
所以這都是一種選擇，選擇之後就要去承擔可能會引發的一些結果
當然也不用再跟大家多說一些風險的東西
因為猴子都知道媽從 2023 到現在就是大多頭
沒有經歷過一些空頭的洗禮或是一些真正大跌的洗禮
其實你不太能夠確定到底你適不適合做這一行
但是換句話說，每一個工作不也是這樣子，你沒有遇到事情前
你也不知道說你到底適不適合這一行
或者說其實你準備了半天去考了某一個
你的家人或是誰叫你去的工作
然後這邊發現自己不喜歡
這種故事我們也聽到很多
所以到最後我還是認為，反正你覺得你有一個想法，你就可以去試試看
不用用太多過來人的經驗去告訴你說，你這樣子忽視風俗什麼的
以前我可能會講這樣的話，現在我都覺得說，反正你覺得可以試試看
你就試試看吧
說不定你真的就是那個沒有到萬中選一啦
其實大概可能五十中選一或是百中選一
就是適合在家這種全職去搞股票，說不定你適合啦
希望你順利
很持久，只要留言不太長都不會跳過
超愛我兩個兒子，感謝 Lisa 老婆
BBCHKA，我們要開抽女兒囉
在肉麻的話，老公都會滿足，靠北，他直接幫我發言
噢，不，該不會以後都會被過濾了
請問孟恭，新手時期有犯哪些錯誤
曾有拗單或是貪貧嗎
好難改掉這個信念，問號，壞習慣
專職這些人，天生特質還是後天訓練的
應該這樣講，像剛剛前面所提到的，那些專門在搞股票的人
也是分成形形色色的人，也是有那種可能強了幾年後又爆炸的
也是有那種我們把它稱為左側交易，反正就是東西越跌越賣
他跌下去有可能就跌半年一年，最後證明他贏之類的
或是說有些就被買掉
那也是有些是完全在做動能
就是我們把它稱為是右側交易
就是東西有漲就一直買，那如果今天開始跌就去減碼或什麼的
那像這個就在過去的一兩禮拜就被修理了
雖然在過去的幾年這樣做都還蠻不錯
但反正總之呢都是不同的階段可能有不同的策略
有些人有多策略，有些人只有單策略或什麼的，那各種人都會有
那凹單跟攤平對有些人來講
他不認為那個叫凹單跟攤平
那個認為叫做封低價碼，便宜我就買更多
那什麼時候會叫做拗單跟貪貧呢
簡單講就是說，你是一個廢韭菜，你不會賺錢，這個就叫做拗單跟貪貧
就像今天有一個人他非常的大膽
然後他可能會去做一些別人不敢做的事情
他如果今天是一個 CEO 或是說董事長的話，大家就說
哇，你看，這個就是人中虎豹，人中龍虎，太厲害了，太有膽識了
你今天如果是一個高中生的話，大家就會說你是 reckless
stupid，你太年輕，你什麼都不懂
所以其實沒有辦法去講某個行為一定是怎麼樣像就在說同樣一個就是一個東西狂跌
然後跌破你的成本一直跌
然後你去買
如果你今天是可能像我身邊的一些我覺得蠻不錯的人在做這件事情
我就會覺得說
你很有 conviction
你一定是非常懂這個公司
你才會這樣子做雖然有些最後面證明你是爆炸或什麼
可是至少大家也都知道怎麼出場
我覺得沒有問題
可是如果今天是隨
便有一個跑來
QA 留言的說
他買了一個東西啊
我現在被套了
怎麼辦
我越買越多
我就知道說你要去死啊
就是就算後來你對
我也覺得你是賽到的
所以你沒有辦法去講說某一個行為一定是怎麼樣
就像你說追高不好嗎
沒有，追高也是可以做的策略
那攤平不好嗎
沒有，攤平也是可以做的策略
你今天是 0050，你在那邊持續的攤平
一個角度叫攤平，另外一個角度叫定期定額
所以像這樣的標的，你要去持續的買
我覺得就是沒有問題，所以不用太講究這些名詞定義的東西
這一看就是你一定還在超早的階段
你不知道說其實同樣的一個東西
你給一個廢酒去用跟給一個強者去用，明明是同樣的一個東西
你說一樣都是使用左側交易
也就是有些人會把它稱為是凹單或是貪品
那有些人就做得跟鬼一樣，有些人做得跟屎一樣
因為選的標的你光是那個眼光就不一樣了
所以他沒有辦法這麼簡單去講
然後再講說有沒有常犯哪些錯誤
基本上不會一直讓自己去犯一樣的錯誤
你看有時候我自己去檢討我自己，我都會立刻去做改進
這點我覺得可能算是我的美德啦
像我上集也跟大家稍微檢討一下，我發現說，我太搶快了嘛
我就立刻去做修正，修正好之後，過去的幾天就蠻舒服的
因為我覺得任何一個錯，然後你還會持續的一直去踩
因為你知道他是錯，你還一直去踩他的話，你就是賭狗啊
簡單來講是這樣，所以就註定失敗
下面有一位，Tony Tsai，誒，孟恭，Perplexity Computer 真的是有點好用耶
那現在還可以用 Fable 5 模型，只是點數燒得有點快
那想問孟恭大什麼情況下會單純用 Claude，那什麼時候會用 Perplexity Computer 啊，感謝
我現在幾乎都是清一色的用 Perplexity Computer
我的 use case 就是我只要有任何的 PDF
那需要去幫他做統整畫表格
或者是我需要去問任何的問題
甚至是我現在看到一些我覺得可能蠻不錯的紅白酒
因為我在研究這個嘛，那我可能就會去讓他幫我去挖說可能哪一個年份是大家比較推崇的
因為我都會先從大家推崇的東西先下去試試看
然後接著再找到自己喜歡的
所以我基本上把所有的生活的應用都已經放在上面了
所以需要一些那種研究成分的
也就是可能過往的 use case
是我要在 Google 上面去看超過五到十個網頁才給我結論的東西
我全部都會放給 perplexity computer 去做
那如果今天是一個問題就可以查出答案的
然後就是可能像一般 Google search 這樣
我還是習慣用 Google，因為 Google 的 AI system 真的非常屌
就是它的那個 AI overview 可以很快的去抓到一些重點
那如果今天是比較偏向是 YouTube 的影片
或者是說一些長篇的文章的話
我就會選擇去使用 Notebook LLM，所以我已經開始有在收斂了
那當然這個收斂是名義上啦
因為實際上 Perplexity Computer 它是去自用了各式各樣的模型
甚至有時候我不會太在意它的模型是用哪一個
要分析的時候還是會用 Cloud 為主
那如果今天是一般的問題的話，我不太在意
我會讓它去用它的那個模型分選器
因為這樣去燒的 Token 也會比較少一點
所以我已經很少去使用模型廠家本身的，他們內建的模型的 chatbot
我已經比較不去做這件事情了，這也是這幾年的
沒有幾年，就是這半個月到一年之間的改變
前陣子質押利率調升，最近我使用的臺新證券不限用途借貸已經全面停止
且發現其他的證券也在更早以前就關閉申請
而且臺新是到期之後就要還錢
不能夠借新還舊了，那想問孟恭對於這件事情的看法
這會不會算是某種利空呢
因為大家要從市場領錢出來去還質押的錢
像這種就比較難以去量化
因為你不知道到底有多少人借錢
你也不知道大家的到期日是不是在同一天
所以如果說大家的到期日理論上是在不同天
因為每個人去借款的時間不一樣
你說散戶的這些鳥資金可以影響到市場，那你也是想太多了
所以那不是一個太大的問題
然後再來是像臺星這樣子應該是比較少數啦
像我自己手上的幾個富邦國泰然後可能統一或什麼
有的沒有的這幾個凱基
他們的一個共同點是他們現在是這樣子
他們會去鎖我的額度舉例來說
我明明可以借兩億
那他現在只讓我借六千萬
就是過往都可以借到兩億
但他現在就說啊
沒有辦法
就你送質押進去
他是不收的那可是呢他不會去讓你沒有辦法續約都還是有辦法續約
所以我覺得可能是看每個不一樣的資金量體
或是你跟券商的交友程度之類來決定說他放多少東西給你
但是他確實是很緊沒錯，甚至我們身邊一些那種蠻大戶的跑去開一部信用圖
他只給他五十萬，殺小，這羞辱人吧，但就真的沒有額度了啦
那所以他不會是一個那種全面的那種像是收散的動作導致資金抽光
因為像我自己就沒有被收散
他只是不讓我放大槓桿而已
所以某個程度上算是被動封控，差不多這樣的一個感受
那下面一位 June, 孟恭去打臺股光通是不是沒有人要的孩子
之前說股價回檔可以聊一下，現在是時候聊一下了嗎
其實我在過去看到蠻多人都一直想要叫我聊光通
只是這些人很特別，他們連留言密碼都抓不太到
因為我就稍微的去滑一下就發現說第一個他們抓不太到留言密碼
第二個是他們連有時候我們在市場上面這個小打的 pass 都收不到
你就想為什麼我不會去聊他，你想一下嘛，為什麼我不會去聊他
我們這麼會抓題材的人
就是為什麼我沒有去聊他
你知道過去就是被動元件
過去就是像他走到了這種主動元件
然後功率元件，然後再來封裝
或者說可能後面遷回臺積
因為市場的資金的取向非常的明顯，那你說光通是不是好東西
絕對都是好東西啊，也是持續的在正確的路上前進
只是股票這種東西有趣的就是像我們前面
過去一陣子幾乎都在 cover 被動銀行的東西
那我會跟大家講說，後面有漲價線要出來，只是我還是要跟你講說
漲價線出來不代表會漲喔
因為漲價線出來就代表說是一般散戶都會知道這個東西可以搞了
可是你看他們買就是買在我們兩三倍的價格之後
然後再問說為什麼會這樣跌
然後再發一些梗圖說什麼陳泰銘在收割大家
不是啊，幹，自己資訊能力差，自己不會做股票，不要亂怪人家
那陳泰銘是多少人的恩人，大概多少
這個市場中的這種中小大戶一起賺到錢或什麼的
所以其實每次一個東西上去跟下來
就是一定會有人賺上很多錢
然後跟有人受傷幹幹叫，然後跟他的孩子說以後不要玩股票
那所以我覺得是這樣子啊
就是我已經算是很民事的
就是我都沒有去跟你聊這個
因為就故事資金都不在這
很明顯
你今天去看一下美股的 Lumen 成 coherent, 或者說臺股這些光相關的東西
你說好不好，其實都好，產業都好，就像是你說 NVIDIA 好不好
好啊，不會漲啊，不會漲沒有用啊，你知道嗎
我們去看市場的東西的時候
我們不是隻是單純的去看產業相關的東西
我們也會去隨著，就像市場資金有沒有在這裡，法蘭有沒有在這裡
你知道嗎
因為我看到太多人一直在問這個，我就知道，因為光前面超熱嘛
所以你不覺得那時候真的敏感度也點很高
我那時候如果我就是在持續跟你聊的話
一定會有一些人就會怪到我身上，就說啊，你看你在高檔拱大腳
即便我們可能在很低檔，就一直在講這個東西，所以對啦
那是有一點那種市場敏感度的東西啊
我覺得因為目前故事就沒在這啊
所以沒什麼好聊的，就可能等到後面有新的故事啊
最近可能有一個新的故事是什麼
發行商他們有搞一個光的 ETF 跟另外一個不知道什麼的 ETF
你可以稍微去看看他的選股啦
我覺得他選到的東西有機會會斷攤一下
有機會，但就很明顯市場的資金沒有在這邊
所以等到後面可能市場的資金跑回來這裡
我們自己的資金也跑回去這邊的時候
你就會發現我們就會去聊這個東西
因為資源是有限的啦，簡單來講是這樣子
所以這就是為什麼我會在市場裡面去抓一些題材
就像過去可能很多人很喜歡價值股
然後他們就說為什麼價值股都沒有在跑
為什麼都是在跑成長股
就是你可以選擇抱怨，你也可以選擇加入
那當然你今天去做投資的話，你自己投資的角度的話
那你不要認為說他是沒有人要的孩子啊
你為什麼不轉個念想說，之前這麼貴你都願意追
現在便宜了，為什麼你不要了
你懂我意思嗎
所以還是要去有一些研究的底子在背後，原因在這邊啦
因為有些東西最後面真的會證明你是對的
只是中間他可能會休息蠻長一段時間
舉例來說像記憶體中間也休息一段時間
然後最後面走了那個後面的那一波嘛
我們不敢說是最後一波啦
只是就是前面也是有橫盤的一大段時間
那我會覺得光通可能也是類似的情形，然後等資金流回去再說
就看一些事件有沒有辦法驅動
像我們剛剛前面講的那些那種顏調機構跑去搞 ETF
就看一下會不會有辦法帶動，如果沒有辦法帶動
如果拉起來馬上要軟掉的話
那就代表錢真的沒有在這邊
下面一位，威格歐，孟恭七月十五號是我生日，可以跟我說那四個字嗎
大鳴大放，自從聽了您的節目跟快樂好朋友們打大混戰開局
一定都是全憑孟恭我老公，希望哪天可以遇到真神
祝您全家快樂平安，愛您喔愛您
最近真的是沒有空去打這些遊戲啦，那也希望以後可以遇到大家
下面一位，會辣的番茄醬是什麼醬
嗨老公，有個基本面的問題想要請益，不知道是哪裡有問題
近期在看驅動 IC 的產業，龍頭那幾支
研究過後發現 2027 的展望都不好
沒錯，那資訊來源各家勸爆
大家都去搞驅動 IC 本業以外的
有的資源放 SOC，有的放電子紙 IC，有的放車用相關
但為什麼股價的線圖拉開現在還是很強，月格局偏右上
是不是我的研究少考慮了什麼要素
導致我的結論跟目前股價呈現相反的狀況
希望得到老公的提點愛您
這位兄弟或這位姐妹所講的東西
就是我們在過去幾集
不是有一直有跟大家聊到說臺灣的一些 design house
然後有一些 DDIC 的東西都在轉強
可是就我們的考察呢
我們發現說
它是成本導向的一個轉價
我們不是一直去聊說成本導向的漲價
然後跟這個需求導向的漲價嘛
那只是就我們看來啦
就是這個成本導向的漲價也都是有成功啦
這些 design house 漲價幾乎都有儲蓄
所以就會導致說有點
像是它前面已經是進入了某一種 button
當然這個 button 不知道什麼時候會 bounce up，會跑出來，會改出這個頹勢
可是至少代表說，就算我現在業績還是維持很平
慘淡，可是至少我把價格反映出去
我的獲益的狀況就會稍微的去做一些改善
所以我覺得他現在在這種 transition 的階段，那只是 transition 的階段
很多時候股價就會先跑
就像剛剛前面所聊到的一些封測的股票
我們也有注意到類似的情形
其實他的產業 bottom 是在
差不多現在， 或者說稍早一點點而已
可是他的股價已經先從底部上來很長一大段了
這就是股票會跑在前面啦
那只是一般後面假設要再繼續上的話， 他就是需要有一些新的故事
這些故事包含但不限於就是本業的改善
他有可能就像你講的， 他去做一個業外的東西
像臺股的有一些工具機的股票， 他不是過去在噴嗎
可是後來噴一噴也蠻多都軟掉了， 為什麼那時候會噴
就是因為他們可能有切到機器人的故事
然後這個機器人的故事，他也不是直接對到終端客戶
他只是出某一個 components 到某一個模組那邊
然後那個模組的終端是用在機器人上面
他就說他自己是機器人，然後他的營收的佔比
那時候我們不是有跟大家聊這一段嗎
就是工業電腦跟一些工具機，他營收佔比是在 5% 以下
超低，3% 或什麼的，可是光是這樣就會噴，為什麼
因為他用他本業的 EPS 去乘上機器人的估值
所以他本質上是某一種 PE Rating 的上修
他是去修他的 PE 先的，他的 Earning 並沒有跟，可是他的 PER
他那個 Ratio 先拉上去了，那股價就跳上去了
所以我會覺得現在有蠻多的 IC Design 都是這樣子
可是有一些 Ice Design，有趣的是
當這個轉折發生的時候呢
你想要去找第一點就不一定找得到了
一個很經典的案例就是，聯發科在他很多漲停之前
大家還記得那時候他手機的東西被下修嘛，然後不是就大逃殺嗎
剛好殺一段，後面大家就進來去買單
他的 AI 故事就啪啪啪啪啪啪
就好幾根漲停就出去了
那出去之後呢
當然你一定就會看到很多人會跑出來幹譙說
那個沒有那麼快啦
他沒有 win 那麼多 case 啊
一堆還在 block on 上面不知道道理大家都懂
可是問題是市場的資金
某個程度上
他們都會有一種那種博弈的心態
你今天如果給他賭到的話
他就是直接在拉上去
他就讓那種想追的人根本就追不到
或是你根本就等不到便宜的價格
那賭錯怎麼辦賭錯就再殺回來而已啊
就這樣而已啊
所以市場的資金會提早去跑
所以有一個說法是這樣說
股市是經濟的櫥窗
這個我覺得大多數的環境下是成立的
不要看那種很短線就拉
可能三個月半年來看
如果說他那個趨勢已經有形成的話
一般就是有一些東西正在巧妙的改變中啦
那目前我們確實是在消費性這邊還沒有辦法看到有好轉的跡象
那確實你的調查也是正確的
就像是大概可能在數個月前我們有跟大家分享說有一些面板
有一些那種消費性的東西，我們注意到他還拉貨
可是我們的判斷是這些不管是什麼 HP 啊，Lenovo 或什麼
他們只是一個補庫存的動作，所以他不會持續
那當然有些人可能光是這個補庫存的動作
他就可以去炒一下股票之類的
但一般要有延續性就一定要有後面的東西
那我目前的看法是跟你一樣
就是目前我們是沒有辦法看到
那當然有一些 Design House 他去做的新東西
那反而是就會類似像那時候的工具機一樣
他有機會就是把那個層數直接拉上去
然後外加，因為他過去沒有漲多
沒有漲多的東西有機會就有一個補漲的行情
那是完全是另外一種做法了
跟平常大家去做的那種可能在 AI 勢頭上的強勢股是不一樣
可是呢，就是落後的東西確實還是有一些補漲的空間
那下面一位，來去菜市場看黑人來喫水果
夢工大人您好，當初是太太推薦才來聽您的節目
一晃眼也三年了，很感謝大大無私的分享
最近太太在求職上不是很順利
遇到的老鳥同事對新人都不是很友善
如果太太能夠找到心儀的工作
我將捐出我月薪的三分之一給流浪動物相關的機構
感謝觀音大愛，因為我今天在外面
但是觀音大愛我們相信他是無遠弗屆的
他應該會聽到，那希望可以讓你的太太也非常感謝他介紹我給你認識
這樣聽起來有點怪怪，就是介紹我的節目給你認識
那希望他可以順利地找到工作
不要遇到一些這種不好的人啦
那希望你們一切平安
好的，掰掰